[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce nouveau numéro de paf on va
essayer de réfléchir sur des situations
un peu compliqué sur ce qui se passe en
amérique avec la sphère floyd sur ce qui
se passe aussi en france avec la sphère
traoré et pour en parler a observé mme
vézina
bonjour bonjour patrice de conférences à
l'université de rouen et à sciences po
florence père cadets choqué bonjour
d'abord la pièce au barreau de
versailles
lorie kane tombeau jours de conférences
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin vous êtes spécialiste de la
civilisation anglo saxon et notamment
des états unis et vous avez publié
plusieurs livres il ya un atlas
historique des états unis qui paraît
chez autrement
et puis un livre qui s'appelle la fin du
rêve américain chez odile jacob et donc
avec vous on va essayer de comprendre
que les racines de ce qui se passe
actuellement de la situation des états
unis actuelle rost bonjour bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes écrivain
vous êtes rappeur vous êtes président de
banlieues actives vous êtes membre du
conseil économique social et
environnemental et vous avez évidemment
elles étaient présents très très
présents dans la sphère traoré jean
baptiste duclair bonjour jean patrice de
conférences à l'université versailles
saint quentin et jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour bonjour êtes éditeur jour
toujours heisbourg militaire qui reprend
un peu de sourire avec représente le
petit dernier est quoi le nantais on
allait subir ce sentiment l'auteur carl
pineau la wii très bien roulé a pris 1
voilà absolument qu'ils avaient pris
pour le grand âge précédent et celui en
est la suite voilà c'est pas le nantais
c'est pas le mari de lulu la nantaise
collection est simple alors on va
peut-être commencer par parler de ce qui
se passe de cette situation aux états
unis là la mort alors
ok qui est officiellement reconnu comme
un assassinat de jazz au funk qui a
provoqué d'immenses manifestations aux
états unis qui provoque aussi des
réactions va en reparler de donald trump
je vous avais peut-être qu'avec glory
kento on essaye de dalé un petit peu
plus loin qu'elles sont au fond on voit
une colère américaine très profonde et
quelles sont les racines
non il ya 2 il ya deux choses
il ya un fond d'inégalités sociales qui
est exacerbée par la crise du coc vide
au niveau santé au niveau économique
et puis il ya ce qui se greffent dessus
des relations on va dire pas forcément
toujours très apaisé à entre les noirs
américains et la police est donc là ce
qu'on a c'est des choses qui sont un pas
inédite puisque des affaires comme ça on
en a eu mais ce qui est nouveau c'est
aussi la médiatisation c'est à dire que
l'on n'a vraiment aucune ambiguïté sur
qui a fait quoi est-ce qu'il ya bénéfice
du doute pas là on a une vidéo très
explicite huit minutes on a aussi des
sondages qui montrent que 70% des sondés
ont vu cette vidéo qui est quand même
considérable
donc il n'y a pas véritablement de deux
possibilités de l'acquittement
et c'est ça qui est vraiment on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure qui
est vraiment le fond du problème c'est
pas fort c'est que c'est pas de temps
évidemment les violences policières sont
le problème mais ce qui accentue le
problème est qu'ils provoquent les
émeutes généralement c'est
l'acquittement
c'est le fait que les poursuites soient
toujours abandonné et qui épate pas de
condamnation donc ça on n'y reviendra
pas avant tout à l'heure parce que ça
accentue le problème mais c'est pour ça
que là on est dans quelque chose qui à
la fois classiques mais également d'une
dimension nouvelle
d'accord est-ce que alors parler
évidemment de 7
situation entre les blancs et les noirs
est ce que c'est un pays calme quand
même élu président ben moi est ce que
c'est il ya quand même un fond de
racisme important encore aux etats-unis
est-ce qu'il ya une inégalité très forte
encore entre les baignoires et les plans
à ces deux questions très différentes
est-ce qu'il faudra inscrire un fond de
racisme ça dépend chez les démocrates
très peu par exemple est de plus en plus
le combat pour l'égalité dans tous les
domaines et ce qui définit les
démocrates donc de toutes façons c'est
vraiment plus quelque chose qui que l'on
peut trouver au ca au sein des
démocrates chez les républicains c'est
aussi discutable c'est à dire qu'il y
aura toute façon il ya du racisme
d'ordre un peu partout donc il y en a
aura peut-être plus chez les
républicains
forcément que chez les démocrates mais
ce n'est pas non plus quelque chose qui
est universel et qui est généralisable
il y aura toujours un fond de racisme
que y aura toujours un fond de racisme
partout les inégalités raciales et les
ségrégations la création de la
ségrégation est quelque chose qui est
très profondément ancré dans l'histoire
américaine à cause de l' esclavage et de
l'après esclavage dont il faut pas
minimiser l'importance tout s'est pas
arrêtée avec lincoln est là et la red
esclavage il ya tout un régime qui suit
pendant un siècle exactement après
qu'ils aient un régime de ségrégation
stricte et légal donc ça c'est une
première chose la deuxième chose qui est
plus pernicieuse c'est les inégalités
combiné c'est à dire qu'ils les
inégalités économiques
les noirs en moyenne gagnent moins
nettement moins que les blancs en
moyenne ça veut pas dire qu'il ya pas
des blancs très pauvres et des noirs
très riche mais enfin bon sur les
moyennes c'est quand même assez éloquent
en termes d'éducation de diplômes c'est
assez éloquent également et il ya un
certain nombre de santé l'état de santé
c'est pour ça que le colis des
particulièrement importante dans cet
épisode là c'est que en amont les noirs
ont un certain nombre de
pathologie type obésité diabète etc qui
sont moins prise en charge parce qu'ils
sont moins assurés parce qu'ils sont
plus loin des hôpitaux etc
donc pour tout ce qui est préventif ils
sont moins bien servis que les blancs
d'une certaine manière au niveau
géographique et au niveau économique
mais également en aval une fois qu'ils
sont malades ils peuvent au moins se
faire soigner parce qu'ils sont plus
loin des hôpitaux parce qu'ils sont
moins couverts et à l'intersection des
deux est le fait qu'au niveau
professionnel
ils sont plus exposés à la pandémie
parce qu'ils ont plus de métiers qui
sont des métiers de première ligne
peuvent pas faire du télétravail
quand ils sont au bas infirmière ou
avalé ce qu'on appelle les flancs de la
gouailleuse
c'est à dire ceux qui sont vraiment au
front donc tout ça s'agrègent c'est des
choses qui sont anciennes toutes ces
inégalités économiques s'agrège à une
crise sanitaire qui est particulièrement
grave aux états unis où les noirs sont
nettement plus affectée en terme de
victimes en termes de morts donc ça
accentue le contexte est là dessus vient
se greffer la sphère la sphère floyd
était donc on a en a un cocktail qui est
particulièrement explosif sur ce sur ce
sujet qui veut intervenir comme
certaines grosses tout en images de
cette crise par ce qui se passe chez moi
là aux états unis
oui alors ben yahia c'est vrai qu'il ya
des données endémique et systémique
c'est à dire qu'il ya ya il y à ces
inégalités qui ont fait partie de
l'histoire des états unis et qui ont de
toute façon même ne serait-ce que
psychologiquement laissé des traces on
qu'il ya quelque chose de beaucoup plus
vif de beaucoup plus à vif dans le
combat actuel pour l'égalité et puis il
ya aussi du systémique comme qui a
retiré et je crois que je termine sur
cette question c'est que ya une crise
sans précédent qui est en train de se
jouer des économies qui fera donc très
violemment socialement
les classes moyennes voire défavorisés
et qui pose la question de l'inégalité
raciale mais je crois qu'au signa
derrière tout ça en conflit juridique
nous avons l'habitude de vivre par
exemple en france avec un droit pénal
qui est très centré sur la question des
discours sur internet ou des discours
haineux ou incitant à la haine ou
incitant à la haine raciale et était à
nouveau un grand arsenal législatif là
dessus alors que les états unis au
niveau fédéral n'avait jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à la discussion de la dernière loi
sur la question
quasiment rien pour pénaliser un délit
pour circonstances aggravantes qui
viendraient être un délit raciale voire
un crime racial et beaucoup d'états
fédérés à la rigueur avait déjà une
législation sur cette question il ya
beaucoup d'inégalités entre les états
donc il n'y a pas vraiment un
une évidence autour du fait qu'un film
raciale est encore plus grave qu'un
autre crime alors ça veut dire aussi que
du coup ça donne des procès qui semble
plus inégalitaire et c'est surtout pour
ça je suis d'accord je pense que c'est
vraiment les suites de cette affaire qui
ravive le fait qu' il y a un besoin
justice et l'égalité dans la justice par
rapport à cette question raciale s'il ya
eu certaines avancées sociales
sociétales notamment avec la présidence
barack obama créé fait croire qu'on
avait dépassé un petit peu ce conflit
racial
je crois que malheureusement avec le
combat plate lanzmann qui est arrivé un
petit peu après tout de suite après
d'ailleurs à l'élection de barak
je crois qu'on se rend compte que ça n'a
été qu'un petit espoir mais qu'il ya
encore un vrai combat à mener sur des
terrains de foot sur les terrains qui
pour moi sont egis l'at-il juridique et
qui démontrerait que l'égalité temps 5 0
ce qui lui a plu évidemment et puis à
cette amérique de troupes quelle est
selon vous la ferez amérique c'est elle
et où elle est comment elle est d'abord
elles sont extrêmement divisée mais des
voix ce qu'elle est mais je pense que
c'est les deux c'est les deux
mais il ya certainement une présence
beaucoup plus forte dans une amérique de
trump de mon point de vue il tout
simplement parce que la plupart des gens
il limite les états unis à new york
or new york est un pays dans le pays le
mélange qui sont à new york
dès que vous sortez de new york vous
sortez des lieux où vous sortez de san
francisco c'est une autre amérique qui
est complètement mais complètement qui
vit en vase clos
qui sait même pas ce que c'est que la
france si vous leur dites la france où
est la france on vous dit à watts
bon voilà donc il ya quand même ce truc
qui est ancré chez eux
donc ces gens là vivent eux avec ce
qu'ils ont toujours appris en tout cas
de ce que pense savoir de leur histoire
en leur histoire on sait comment elle
s'est construite et s'il y avait un
minimum d'instruction que eux-mêmes
sache d'où ils viennent d'ailleurs parce
qu'ils sont construits sur un génocide
malgré tout les les états unis donc je
pense que tout ça si on enseigne est
réellement il je pense que certains
d'entre eux prendrait un peu un peu de
hauteur avec tout ça mais et je rejoins
mais parfaitement ce qui vient de se
dire par anne charlotte et et et lorik
c'est on est on est dans un on est
vraiment dans judas dans une amérique
qui est d'ailleurs vous prenez les
élections présidentielles par exemple
hillary clinton avait été élu par le
peuple
ce sont les grands électeurs qui ont mis
trois heures à la plage et ça c'est le
système
oui bah c'est leur système il arrive
malheureusement c'est comme il l'a dit
d'ailleurs oui mais ça sont d'importance
ce a son importance
donc après c'est leur système de jeu
c'est un les gars à l'égard dû
système en tant que tel toutefois sur la
question sur l'acte il ya une vraie
ségrégation une vraie ségrégation aux
états unis elle existe elle continue le
l'histoire de du vivre ensemble on en
parle en france mais aux états unis et
vivent côte à côte
et d'ailleurs nous mêmes ici petit à
petit on y arrive d'ailleurs avec tout
ce qui se passe depuis des années et est
7 ème capacité justement des politiques
des médias à à pouvoir créer un terreau
fertile pour que on n'arrive pas à ça
parce que plus ça va aller plus les
inégalités se creusent et plus il va y
avoir cette division est et ce repli
entre guillemets communautariste qui
fait aussi peur aux uns et aux autres
mais ça ce n'est que la résultante de
donner des politiques pour le concours
met en place le ring n' roll et c'est
peut-être pour répondre un petit peu à
ce que vient de dire en fait le tout ce
qui tout ce qui unit tous ça c'est le
système fédéral c'est à dire qu'on parle
des grands électeurs on parle d de
l'éducation qu'on parle de ce genre de
choses en fait tout ça c'est l'élection
de police et des questions qui sont des
questions locales à des questions
municipales c'est à dire que l'élection
de barack obama n'a strictement rien
changé dans les questions de police et
c'est pour ça que black ice matters
arrive à ce pendant le mandat de barack
obama
c'est parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
rapports véritablement entre les deux
sinon qui a eu et attendent qu'ils ont
été déçus
ça c'est une première chose au niveau de
l'éducation je pas tout à fait d'accord
parce que dans certains est en fait
l'éducation les programmes scolaires
sont décidés au niveau des états et dans
certains états pour quand même
travailler un petit peu la laddh dans
les programmes scolaires on insiste
énormément sur le poids historique dès
la construction des états unis les
relations avec les amérindiens
l'esclavagé c'est quelque chose qui est
très présent en 2019 on a assez livrer
ou commémorer plutôt les 400 ans des
premiers esclaves qui sont arrivés à
jamestown on en a énormément parlé de ce
qu'on appelle
le péché originel de l'amérique baleines
encore utilisé la formule il ya quelques
jours donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
est quand même très présent il ya
quelques étapes c'est peut-être moins
présent dans les programmes parce que
les programmes sont aussi un enjeu
politique très fort par exemple au texas
comment on est comme on enseigne son
histoire c'est un enjeu politique
mais globalement il ya quand même
d'énormes progrès qui ont été faits
depuis les années 60 sur c'est sur ces
questions là un tout petit point sur ce
que design charlene une toute petite
nuance ce qu'on appelle les red wings
vont être punit très sévèrement pour les
civils mais la différence ça va être que
pour les policiers ils vont être moins
sévèrement punis parce qu'ils vont pas
être qualifié comme ça parce qu'en fait
le noeud du problème c' est l' influence
des syndicats de policiers dans le
règlement des conflits qui sont des
conflits qui sont pas des conflits
fédéraux des conflits au niveau de
l'état mais des conflits qui sont
généralement locaux et municipaux et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette espèce
de disparités mais quiconque quiconque
vous et moi comme ils commettraient ce
qui est qualifié de eight crâne donc un
crime et nous comme on traduit un peu
plus rapidement en france est donc un
crime raciste ou un crime antisémite ou
homophobes etc
nous on prendrait nettement plus parce
qu'on n'a pas de syndicat de nous qui
nous protégerait justement vous parliez
du système fédéral qui était très
important de nos et agit quand on entend
dire je vais envoyer la garde nationale
je vais passer au dessus justement du
fédéralisme je vais je vais envoyer la
garde nationale s'il est si les
gouverneurs ne le font pas c'est aussi
la séduction de contestation de ce
système fédéral ps que c'est est ce que
c'est bien vu ces états unis bah ça
dépend pour qui alors être up
il ya une toute petite nuance c'est que
trump a le droit du d'envoyer la guerre
nationale
non alors il a le droit à washington dc
parce que washington dc est un district
est pas un état c'est la seule quelques
possibilités mais dans les états il n'a
absolument pas le droit l'histoire de
l'insurrection actes j'ai envie de lui
dire bonne chance donald asie on regarde
ça va être ça va donner non il a dans
tous les cas où il une séléction a été
invoquée ça a été quand les débats quand
quand les gouverneurs se sentait
dépasser qu'ils avaient besoin du
soutien fédéral et le fédéralisme en
fait le niveau fédéral est un niveau de
soutien
c'est un niveau de logistique entre les
états comme nous on a entre les régions
mais c'est aussi un niveau de soutien
vous n'y arrivez pas je vais vous aider
il ne peut pas envoyer l'armée s'en
lasser une forme de coup d'état
le sun qui a essayé de faire ça au
moment de katrina c'était 7 et george
bush et il a eu les 50 gouverneurs
contre lui et la décision était retoqué
par la justice
donc c'est juridiquement possible
ensuite ça répond à certaines
aspirations vous avez des gens qui ont
envie d'envoyer les chars sur les
antifas sur les manifestants et c'est ça
oui il ya toujours dans tous les pays il
ya des gens qui ont envie qu'on envoie
les charmes au premier problème mais
globalement ce qu'on a eue hier soir
heure française soit au début de la nuit
heure française c'est une lettre d'un
certain général mattis qui a servi sous
le gouvernement a truck a démissionné
avec pertes et fracas qui est vénéré
dans l'armée et qui a dit que trump
était une menace pour le pays commence à
y avoir un certain nombre de
personnalités influentes des militaires
des retraités de la cia qui sont pas
exactement des gauchistes et distante
ifart et un certain nombre à la fois de
pasteur l'archevêque de washington n'est
pas non plus un baba cool et pat
robertson qui était un des architectes
de la droite religieuse dans les années
80 qu'ils disent
un fois arrêté avec les chars et tout ça
et deux foires été utilisée la bible à
tort et à travers cinq jours et par des
gens qui sont peu suspect de sympathies
gauchistes robertson c'est quand même un
des plus un des plus à droite de la
droite religieuse donc quand ces gens là
disent qu'il faut peut-être arrêter un
petit peu ça des sacrilèges ça commence
à faire beaucoup
en 48 heures est sûre sur la défense
justement il ya james mattis qui est
l'ancien v10 de la défense qui
critiquent beaucoup de sempé marc hester
qui l'actuel qui a été très gêné par
papa par le par les propos de tout mais
ce ne sera pas la loi et à l'ordre quand
même
il faut dire que jusqu'en janvier en
gros la réélection de 39 c'est pas de
problème il ya eu là dessus la coquille
vide et il ya là dessus est en
difficulté je pense que ça joue aussi
dans ses réactions dans le rich
oui oui et les sondages sont pas bons du
tout à la main des sondages indéterminée
sans elle il ya une patrie de sondages
en gros à chaque fois le mardi 2
mercredi au texas il ya plus un c'est un
républicain à +1 au texas c'est cet
angle dans tous les sondages il a - 6 -
7 - 11 dans le dernier moins de neuf
donc c'est quand même assez
catastrophique et le problème c'est que
ça fait boule de neige
ils essayent de remobiliser sa base en
agitant un peu les chars à tout ça le
problème c'est que c'est contreproductif
avec le problème est donc le problème de
la coved il il a touché dois remercier
tous chez les personnes âgées
et donc on a vu que l'aller chez les
personnes âgées qui était un peu une
partie de son socle
il était descendu donc l'aï lancée en
train de il a une base qui est assez
solide mais qui quand même relativement
insuffisante
non au lieu de l'élargir en fait elle
est en train de s'effriter et donc ils
essayent de la consolider mais c'est
encore plus contre-productif
donc oui il a une nature à attiser les
tensions mais c'est également
contre-productif et donc là le problème
c'est qu'il sait pas faire autre chose
il sait pas faire le président il sait
pas faire le rassembleur et donc bien il
est un petit peu ça assez y ait une
certaine manière c'est un petit peu et
canard sans tête quand il tourne en rond
depuis lors qu'elle est peut-être oui
c'est vrai il joue et où jean charles
il joue la division combien toutes les
présences dit comme tout président dans
ces circonstances et cm2 de jouer le
rassemblement de la mairie que lui joue
vraiment la division peut-être parce que
il ya cinq ans même cette échéance
électorale
il ya toujours été diviseur depuis le
début je crois qu'il allait son
tempérament céda d'attiser d'attiser les
haines d'attiser les oppositions alors
je pense qu'il a peut-être réalisé qu'il
ne pouvait pas envoyer l'armée parce que
j'ai cru entendre ce matin la radio
qu'il renonçait envoyée
a envoyé l'armée je pense qu'il ya enfin
écouter peut-être un conseil juridique
et keith éthique qu'il est d'aller dans
le mur ramenée à 2 puis 2 puis bien
début de sa présidence il des danses est
dans cette posture
effectivement il ne peut être qu'un
petit le rythme à un canard sans tête
qui sait pas faire autre chose c'est
dans son si gêné par ces jeunes d'être
comportement d'être d'être ainsi donc
c'est plutôt les etats-unis sont à feu
et à sang et je connais personne d'autre
nouveau - que vous l'aurez 2010 qu'il ya
une traîne dans le tac entre les pro et
les anti autre piste et que je crois
franchement ça se passe mal dans la
population elle-même génie aux états
unis au moment où il y avait la campagne
2010 est et est en fait c'était bon
enfant eux ce qui tenait des tableaux
très des supermarchés et puis les autres
il a une qui te là je pense que ça va
assez mal sa série en et fiction
élections
c'est vrai qu'on sent un pays
extrêmement divisé pour le mois et
bielle et puis il ya quand même les
conséquences de la que vides au sépia
new york hyper classe et enfin les
magasins sont pillés les fermes et enfin
c'est une ville qui est devenu
méconnaissable
c'est vrai que les conséquences aussi de
la crise de l'accueil vides ont été
incroyables et le système le système
n'étant pas le même qu'en france déjà
nous on a on a malgré tout et ça il faut
le il faut le répéter à chaque fois on a
cette chance
et moi je vais je répète souvent une
phrase ddtm qui dit quelle chance quelle
chance d'habiter la france dommage que
des gens fassent preuve de tant
d'incompétence et malheureusement c'est
ce qui nous met un peu au fond des fois
mais mais on a quand même cette chance
d'habiter en france et 2 et d'avoir lu
malgré tout les mesures quel que soit ce
qu'on peut reprocher on en achète
d'ailleurs parlé dans cette émission au
gouvernement la gestion de cette crise
au départ et tout ça mais je trouve que
les mesures qui ont été mises en place
pour soutenir
l'activité en tout cas pour soutenir les
entreprises et tout ça a quand même
limité la casse or aux états unis le
système n'est absolument pas le même et
on a vu en plus et c'est ce que disait
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure le reach c'est
que vous avez une aile mais de telles
inégalités est due aussi à la question
raciale que effectivement le plus lourd
tribut a été payée l'agissement cette
communauté noire
il suffit de vous prenez la mieux
orléans il et les chiffres ils sont
effarants vous avez 78 % des gens qui
sont morts de du duc au vide c'est son
fond noir
donc il y a un problème profond là
dessus et new york est une ville
effectivement moi j'adore cette ville
parce que je trouve qu'il ya ya une vie
à une énergie il ya un mélange même si
les gens même si on voit quand même que
les gens vivent côte à côte
il ya quand même quelque chose d'assez
magic dans cette ville là effectivement
moi j'ai eu mes amis qui est qui et qui
habite là-bas je peux vous dire qu'il
était mais dans une espèce de dépression
par rapport à la situation et ces
charniers qui ont été ouverts or à
central park
du côté d'harlem et tout ça c'est quand
même enfin c'est des images qui vont
marquer les gens à vie jean baptiste et
jean-charles globalement encore
aujourd'hui est ce que si on simplifiait
pas au fond les choses et j'ai je parle
sur le comptant de leur équipe
évidemment un président américain est
réélu quand la croissance est bonne et
il est battu par la croissance des
panneaux est ce qu'est ce que c'est pas
un peu c'est peut-être un peu
simplificateur mais est-ce que c'est pas
un peu vrai il voulait former les gens
et surtout un peu tôt pour le dire parce
que là en cinq ans cinq mois les choses
peuvent
évoluer peut-être même s'améliorer
donc on va voir c'est à dire c'est
vraiment à la fin du bal qu'on paie les
musiciens et que l'avons conjoncture
beaucoup comme il ya une certaine rage
évidence et c'est toujours plaisant et
c'est toujours payant d'attaqué trump et
d'attaquer lors balala on peut tirer à
boulet rouge en tout en toute liberté
mais voilà peut-être un peu tôt un peu
tôt pour dire ça y est c'est fini on est
débarrassé de ce ce triste sire où on
verra on est en avant que les que des
choses catastrophiques jean-charles se
rappelle camus à propos de la
catastrophe il ya deux morts en france
qu'aux états unis ou que je souhaite
qu'on a tendance à oublier je le
rappelle donc que c'est toujours facile
de 2,2 de critiquer mais voilà bon c'est
celle de le bilan de l'accord vide n'est
pas là ensuite vous avez fait une sorte
de demain de gamme en nous disant que
new york auraient été pillés à quoi de
la copie c'est quand même beaucoup plus
à cause des récentes émeutes s'est pas
vu de gens piller new york à cause de
lags de du coronavirus enfin ou alors je
ne comprends pas les images et je suis
dans un autre monde mais c'est celle là
où les pillages dans les magasins de la
5e avenue n'ont aucun rapport avec la
copine
voilà donc attention à ça mais en
revanche s'il ya quelque chose de tout à
fait on peut qu'être d'accord avec
l'analyse de lorik et youtube vivement
épatante et plutôt gentil bien
incontestable d'eau donc donc ça on est
tous d'accord
est ce que je raconte est au tout début
de l'émission était vraiment intéressant
c'est que on a aux états unis
si on en vient au départ de cette
discussion sur l'assassinât de floyd
c'est des images qui sont actuellement
un compte et ça indéniable qui nous
colle à bayda et des violences que
l'attitude de la police qui met qui met
un genou à terre l'attitude de gens
qu'ils soient républicains démocrates et
c'est qu'ils sont là entrain dire bah
oui là il ya une faute manifeste est
quelque chose de dramatique n'y a pas
débat
voilà et ça c'est des extrêmement
extrêmement sain il ya aucun débattu sur
l'ignominie de ce fait sur le racing
s'est reconnue
chaque mois florence mercredi oui pour
revenir sur votre question à patrice sur
les présidents qui sont élus quand crime
obligation économique saint-charles il
reste quelques mois avant le mois de
novembre mais je suis assez convaincu
que à la rentrée du mois de septembre
les états unis
économiquement pour être être très très
très affaiblie tout comme la france être
affaibli autant il n'y a pas de raison
qu aux etats unis sa rampe actes
beaucoup plus vite qu'en france compte
tenu d'un nombre de chômeurs absolue il
pharand aux états unis d'absence
d'ailleurs de soutien de ces chômeurs
même système que nous et je suis assez
convaincu qu'au mois de septembre ça va
être économiquement très difficile pour
les américains de toutes ses formes est
simplement pour dire que je ne pense pas
que la la crise économique aura un
impact direct sur donald trump en tout
cas on ne peut pas imputer à donald
trump qui arrive puisque tout simplement
lié d'arriver encore la cape et
médiatement meshaal accès du comité je
crois qu'effectivement ce conte est un
petit peu le ton à paulhan donald trump
essaye de le chercher tout simplement un
ennemi c'est ce qu'il sait faire donc
son ennemi ça a été les chinois et c'est
pour aujourd'hui
ça permet aussi cristallisé le débat
politique s'est-il le désordre sous les
apparences d'un président comment
dirais-je garant de la sécurité
nationale il excite effectivement
lienneman à travers la situation vous
connaissez pas dire qu'à une violence
physique je le s'ajoute une violence
symbolique juste un tout petit monde
certes jean baptiste on peut pas lui
imputer la qu'ovide n'a en revanche on
peut lui imputer les décisions qu'il a
prises sur le plan économique qui était
quand même des décisions court termisme
d'accord et je pense qu'il va aussi le
payer très cher rameau ou peut-être pour
conclure ce débat vrai qu'avec john
semble assez absent mais c'est vrai
qu'il a une popularité très très forte
dans la population
moi celui qu'on voit et qu'on entend
c'est le ba ba alors de petites choses
déjà un niveau au niveau économique il
faut bien dissocier que la situation
économique va être très variables d'un
état à l'autre et que dans les élections
c'est ça qui compte
mais également que dans un même état ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est que la
situation économique varie énormément
d'une catégorie à l'autre c'est à dire
que le chômage va affecter beaucoup plus
les noirs qui de toute façon ne la
votent pas républicain donc si les
blancs sont moins affectées ils seront
peut-être moins vent debout contre
trèbes donc ça attention dendre même et
rien ça peut jouer énormément et ces
disparités économiques qui peuvent être
local baida non l'entente avec
parcimonie il peut pas être non plus par
tous parce que sinon on l'accuserait
opportunisme c'est le problème c'est que
si vous êtes trop la rosée cus
d'opportunisme si vous n'êtes pas assez
là on dit que vous êtes absent donc il
est obligé de gérer la quantité de sa
parole ce que trump ne fait pas parce
qu'il fait il arrive à faire 120 plus
par jour et là ça nous le mène à obama
obama a une parole qui est assez rare
parce que les anciens président quel
qu'il soit george bush c'est pareil les
paroles assez rare ce qui rend leur
parole à ces précieuses donc quand ils
disent quelque chose on écoute même
concept george deubeuliou bouger sert
que de trump a quand même réussi à faire
passer de change de peau du boucher
quelques mois pour qu'elle pourra pour
un vieux sage raisonnable c'est quand
même assez
mais c'est cette rareté de la parole qui
la rend à ces précieuses mais également
il permet de contraster avec le côté un
petit peu bouillonnant de trump obama
rappelle ce que c'est qu'un président à
président c'est sage c'est calme c'est
rassembleur et ça ça souligne le
contraste entre ces deux personnalités
c'est pas une question de politique au
sens pour laisser aux seuls les
politiques ont fait mais une question de
style
est-ce qu'on va retrouver j'ai eu
plusieurs discussions à ce sujet là on
se retrouve un peu en 2012 en france
quand une partie de la droite française
n'en pouvait plus de sarkozy et pas
seulement de sarkozy mais de
l'hystérisation des médias des
politiques etc sur le climat sarkozy et
se disait bon à tort ou à raison
finalement avec hollande hollande n'est
pas aubry il est plus modérée au moins
ce sera plus calme et la somme
d'instinct on a des républicains qui
disent on n'en peut plus bas y donne
c'est pas sanders au moins va retrouver
un vrai président ce sera plus calme
d'accord alors on va passer à un autre
sujet mais qui peut être assez proche et
zézé interrogé d'abord reste là dessus
c'est à dire qu'on va regarder ce qui se
passait en amérique et puis surgit où
ressurgit la sphère traoré il ya eu
beaucoup de comparaisons certains disent
ces deux affaires très semblable au fond
d un peu de myrys passe ici ce qui se
passe ici c'est un miroir de ce qui se
passe de ses états unis est ce que c'est
votre votre analyse rost mais on ne peut
pas s'empêcher de faire un parallèle
même si les histoires sont complètement
différentes il ya quand même des
similitudes dans la manière dont les
choses se passent
je veux dire une interpellation qui se
termine par la mort d'un jeune qui plus
est été sportif et la conclusion entre
guillemets pour l'instant
des expertises ont été ordonnées par la
justice est peu et les morts entre
guillemets d'une crise cardiaque
sauf que et le démontrer donc toutes ces
expertises l'a d'ailleurs qu' il y a
élément par axe qui si bon
la contre-expertise qu'a demandé la
famille à chaque fois a été rejetée par
la justice
ils ont réussi eux mêmes à faire faire
par des médecins
une contre-expertise quiconque qui
confirme qu'un il est mort des suites du
fait que les policiers l'avaient entre
guillemets étouffés parce que le après
pour l'instant il ya l affaire suit son
cours la seule chose qu'on veut c'est
que ça ne se termine pas comme toutes
les autres affaires
je peux vous en citer un jeune de mon
quartier de ménilmontant qui ment
exactement dans les mêmes conditions
dans le car des policiers il ya une
quinzaine d'années de ça ça fait 15 ans
que la famille se bat elle n'a jamais
jamais pu avoir un procès tout
simplement parce que la justice la
police ils ont décidé de ne pas aller au
bout de cette affaire alors qu'il est
mort c'est un sportif c'est un jeune
homme qui était qui faisait plein de
sports qui n'avait jamais eu le moindre
problème
et tous les ans en plus vous êtes
obligés de faire est d'aller faire une
visite médicale pour les sports qui
pratiquait il n'y a jamais eu le moindre
truc a été détecté et ça a été la
conclusion c'est que il est mort d'une
crise cardiaque et donc et et je peux
vous en citer d'autres
et aujourd'hui les gens disent ça suffit
ça suffit
il ya un élan au niveau mondial qui dit
il ya un peuple qui subit depuis
toujours qu'il n'a jamais mis personne
personne en esclavage qui n'a jamais
colonisé qui que ce soit et qui subit en
permanence par lesquels je suis pas je
suis pas dans la victimisation
parce que dès qu'on parle de ça on le
dit oui mais vous êtes dans la
victimisation ou non
moi je suis tout sauf une victime tu met
une claque jetons pas l'autre joue donc
ça c'est une chose claire et notre
génération et l1 elle est complètement
comme ça donc que on veut pas être
dessus de qui que ce soit on veut juste
que ça soit exactement la même chose et
que et que cette mentalité qui a été
acquise au vu de l'histoire par rapport
au fait qu'il ya eu justement cette
colonisation il ya eu cette suprématie
qui a été imposé entre guillemets
euh de l'homme blanc sur le noir en tant
que tel malheureusement inconsciemment
c'est quelque chose qui est inscrit dans
la tête de beaucoup de chants et
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui disent ça
suffit on ne peut plus continuer aux
états unis à chaque fois à chaque fois
il n'y a jamais de condamnation quand la
spirale de la mort ne sont jamais
inquiétés
en france c'est exactement la même chose
pour les bavures policières
les affaires ne vont pratiquement jamais
au bout et il n'y a pratiquement jamais
de condamnation est donc là ce que veut
la famille traoré est ce que veulent les
gens qui se mobilisent vous rendez
compte il y avait je ne sais pas si les
gens se rendent compte de ce qui se
passe là les chiffres de la police il
parle de vingt mille personnes
mais moi je peux vous dire qu'il est
évidemment ils ont toujours l'habitude
est divisé par trois ou quatre
mais les chiffres des manifestants et là
je peux vous dire qu'il y avait un monde
de 100 lits sur cet essai en train de
gangréner l'ensemble de notre société et
du monde il n'y avait pas que des n'y
avait pas que des noirs
d'ailleurs parce que d'habitude qu'on
laisse ces affaires là moi j'ai été à
plein de manifestations la première
manifestation pour adama traoré tous
âges y était et c'est vrai que la grande
majorité pratiquement tous les gens qui
étaient présents
c'était des gens qui étaient issus de la
communauté si on peut mais d'ailleurs
parler de communauté de la communauté
noire
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est l'ensemble
des gens donc il s'agit pas de dire que
les blancs si les blancs ça où on s'en
foutent ça nous c'est pas ça qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui on parle d'une
question d'humanité d'humanité de
respect de la vie humaine quelle qu'elle
soit toutes les vies doivent valoir le
même prix
face à pezens justice et face à la
justice
c'est ce qu'on réclame qui est un procès
après personne ne détient la vérité
appart les policiers eux mêmes les
gendarmes qui étaient là ce jour là
c'est eux qui détiennent la vérité mais
il faut qu'il y ait un procès pour qu'on
puisse confronter les différentes
versions pour que la vérité juridique
judiciaire puisse sortir de cette
affaire là on veut pas que ça soit
étouffé comme ça a été fait on veut pas
que personne ne soit inquiété dans cette
affaire comme ça a été le cas dans la
feria déboule à mushin l'art admis
riad hamlaoui je peux vous en citer des
tonnes lamine dieng tout ça je le vois
là je savais que un moment ça suffit
c'est vrai que au delà alors après on
peut on peut parler d expertise qui sont
contradictoires et c'était un peu ce que
disait le ricanement sur ce qui se
passait généralement aux états unis ce
qui est l'ennemi de tout ça c'est quand
même l'incertitude c'est quand même
qu'on ne sait pas c'est eux
bah tout le monde voudrait savoir quelle
a été la réalité de cette bof ça soit
faute des policiers que ça soit autre
chose qu'elle soit naturelle
on le saura mais c'est vrai que son
salon peut pas contester que le frais
qui en hausse et que les choses soient
claires on puisse savoir ça permettrait
quand même de résoudre une partie de la
sphère même s'il y avait il ya des
malades ont dû bien évidemment sur le
sua foot ou au suicide est assez c'est
un tout petit peu ce qu'il fait comme
d'habitude par des propos de rose qui
nous parle maintenant d'un peu à change
voir l'homme blanc si je puis dire de
2,2 tout 2 2 tout arrêt de tout défaut
donc je ne sais pas du tout ce que j'ai
dit jean-charles on les avait il me
semble que dans l'île ont formé propos
jean charles
non je vous avais dit ce peuple noir qui
n'a jamais mis personne en éclairage
oui et elle avait dit et alors il me
semble que les exemples sont nombreux de
de gens qui ont vendu sur la côte
africaine leur propre leur foi pour
ressortissants contre eux quelques
quelques kilos de verroterie dans
quelles conditions s'est jamais passé
ça c'est la commission dans quelles
conditions dites non à refaire vous me
faites rire parce que vous vous faites
vous pour une fois je vais préciser jean
charles que je ne les ai pas parlé
rusedski pas question c'est pas une
question non mais ne déformez juste pas
mes propos
les peuples noirs très bien bon le moi
je parle pas du peuple blanc c'est pour
moi le peuple noir n'existe pas de
peuple blanc n'existe pas voilà je pense
que c'est spécial quand même mieux
ensuite sortir c'est très facile c'est
très payant une litanie de noms que
personne ne connaît ou pour en sortir
des milliers de rentes et remettre crise
de jeter de revenir à 25 ans alors sur
le dieu internet vers quelqu'un
qu'est-ce que ça prouve que je
reviendrai
ce que vous dites patrice bien
évidemment qu'il faut que la lumière
soit faite mais bien évidemment mais qui
qui le conteste et qu'il honnit
personnes simplement cette espèce de
bagarres veut dire une expertise contre
notre expertise laissons la justice de
la justice en france est quand même
relativement saine
il ya des gagnants il ya des auxiliaires
de justice qui font leur boulot voilà
arrêtons de toujours jeter de l'anathème
sur ce qui fonctionne bien en france etc
ensuite après alors évidemment là pour
une fois les 20000 même même la famille
parle de 20000 et roth veut nous en a
ajouté trois fois plus
elle est encore évident mais c'est déjà
beaucoup et les commerçants du quartier
de la villette pense que c'est largement
assez 20000 et que voilà c'est s'il
avait une petite chance de s'en sortir
maintenant c'est définitivement mort
parce que les après après ce qui s'est
passé
donc les laissant la justice faire son
coup n'essayons si c'est possible de ne
pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu pour
essayer que ça saute à peu près partout
de 2,2 de faire en sorte que les gens
manifestent quand je vois qu'elle ait
des députés des gens de la
représentation nationale qui ont été
élues qui appellent aux manifestations
interdites en disant de toute façon on
s'en moque il faut manifester
et peu importe tout tout ce qui peut se
passer j'ai versé c'est un comportement
qui me paraît assez peu démocratique à
ses poufs st voilà maintenant je reviens
là on en arrive à savoir la vérité sur
le faire favori c'est indispensable d
évidemment combien après la première
question la comparaison en toile
l'amérique et la france en termes
d'argent je ne sais pas si la
comparaison mérite d'être mené jusqu'à
son terme mais il ya une chose que moi
je crois que en tout cas la france et
les états unis échouent à garantir c'est
que nous ayons aujourd'hui à parler de
ça et là je rejoins totalement vote mais
je pense que jean-charles rejoint m6 ne
faudrait plus que ce genre d'affaires
arrive pas parce qu'on a quand même à
faire à deux situations dramatiques dans
lesquelles quelque les faits parce qu'il
faut savoir que de toute façon
georges claude lui même s'ils s'étaient
rendus coupables d'infractions sa mise
dans la pile
6 il vaut mieux que ça n'arrive pas à
l'attention de ceux qui nous écoutent
mais mais on ne peut pas dans une
démocratie qui se respecte avec tout ce
que nous avons comme arsenal de
législation sur les droits de l'homme
considéré que c'est normal qu'on meurt à
la suite d'une garde à vue d'une
interpellation alors malheureusement ce
qu'on appelait le père vieux policière
ça a fait des très beaux films français
américains et ça aussi ça fait partie de
la fin de la part des erreurs humaines
mais on roule on doit aujourd'hui
réfléchir à la manière dont réprime
c'est fait pour que justement la
question des violences policières n'est
même plus court dans une société moi je
crois que justement on sera apaisée sur
le climat raciale et sur le givre
ensemble qui nous manque tellement en
cette période de covin moi je crois
qu'on sera apaisée à partir du moment où
ces violences policières ou ce type
d'infraction là ne peuvent plus exister
et je crois n'a pas forcément un arsenal
juridique assez puissant pour le rythme
des appareils des syndicats de policiers
aux états unis qui du coup sont sont
très puissants et c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de blocages qui sont dus à cela
mais en coin sociaux on n'avance pas
juhasz et sur ces questions et c'est
dommage parce que du coup même dans ce
qu'on avait eu comme répression
policière au niveau des jets les jo
débat on a l'impression que la police
joue le rôle des méchants alors que le
départ de hosni ont peur d'y aller
maintenant il faudrait arriver à recréer
la confiance avec un droit juste
équitable ce qui donne le sentiment à
tout le monde d'être entendu on ne
devrait même pas comment se faire
qu'avec jean baptiste gens l'avaient
deux titres de la presse du jeudi matin
le parisien
un policier dit non la police française
n'est pas raciste et libération et des
violences policières l'hôte état
d'urgence
est ce que une atmosphère de violence
policière quand même et depuis la sphère
des gilets jaunes en effet
ces présentes en france oui ça c'est sûr
qu'il y avait des dérapages qui sont
assez inadmissible je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs causes aussi ses dérapages
je pense qu'il ya un problème de
formation déjà à la base des policiers
est née je sais pas comment se passe
leur formation en tout cas ils ont
formation qui est répressive plus qu'une
formation qui pourrait être préventive
discussions avec avec les citoyens et
puis deuxièmement je pense que les
policiers sont totalement épuisé à bout
je pense qu'ils sont assez mal traitée
aussi ils font des heures sup ils sont
pas ils sont pressurisées parce que
c'est difficile à supporter et après les
différents mois qu'ils ont passés sur
les problématiques de gilet jaune je
poussais manifestations qu'a pu avoir
derrière c'est assez compliqué pour déjà
s'il était reconnu et former serait
correct est considéré par ne serait-ce
que leur hiérarchie et correctement
payés on serait peut-être pas dans aussi
dans une situation aussi à vif
mais avec des réactions totalement
disproportionnée maintenant c'est vrai
qu'on dame qu'ils ont je ne peux pas me
laisser aller la chercher de la partie
jean baptiste sursis puis le pilori cân
tho sur la comparaison avec la mecque
amérique
jean baptiste simplement pour rappeler
que l'état dispose de la puissance
créative l'insee d'état qui dispose de
la force et c'est bien que ça soit unie
qui en disposent évidemment tous ceux
abandonnés dans un dimanche le contrat
social qui lie à particules et à cette
capacité que nous avons à détruire a
planté à inventer je dis ça simplement
pour mettre en perspective aussi cette
idée de violence puisque forcément le
niveau de risque comparé à la justice
des pentes son niveau de responsabilité
il est vrai que c'est la police
donc qui dispose de 7 2 7 me sens de
cette force dont il faut rappeler
d'ailleurs qu' il faut se mettre à la
place aussi les forces de l'ordre il
n'est pas difficile d'intervenir dans
des conditions qui soient parfaitement
sereine puisque la violence c'est aussi
le le règne de la réactivité de la
vitesse et que parfois qui manque à des
dérapages qui se sent absolument
incontestable et qu'il faut condamner il
faut évidemment les forces judiciaires
mais il faut aussi rappeler qu'ils sont
celles policiers qui sans cesse se
posent parfois même face à quelqu'un qui
a relais et qui pointe un pistolet dans
l'eau comment va faire appliquer le code
de procédure pénale donc ça je pense que
c'est important de le rappeler
et puis la deuxième chose c'est ensuite
d'être prudents s'ils sur la
qualification qu'on pourrait donner une
situation qui nous font donné par la
presse je pense qu'il faut évidemment
faire confiance à notre faire confiance
à la justice ne veut pas forcément dire
que la justice dit toujours la vérité
et ce n'est pas l'accusé que de le dire
c'est simplement dire que la justice n'a
pas toujours les moyens de savoir ce
qu'il s'est exactement passé et deux
soeurs ne peut pas blâmer la justice je
crois que l'incertitude qui est propre à
cette fonction il faut l'arrêter mais il
faut aussi quelque part la déchirer
puisque si on ne sait pas peut pas
cependant se prononcer en ce sens va
finalement au vu de ce qui se passe je
crois que le policier est en panne je
crois qu'il faut toujours garder le plus
de prudence que je pense aussi c est ce
qu il faut remarquer c'est que tout
dépend de l'encadrement et du
commissaire de police qui est dans un
commissariat de police à l'occasion de
plusieurs permanences que j'avais dans
des gardes à vue voir qu'il ya des
commissariats qui peuvent être beaucoup
plus violente parce que le commissaire
de police et un shérif et entraîne ses
hommes comme un peu à chérif et j'ai vu
ce commissariat pour changer parce que
le commissaire de police étaient partis
qui a un autre qui arrive et qui a perdu
tout de même politique et qui a plus une
politique préventive et et ça aussi
c'est très important dans la façon dont
seront gérés il faut alors encore une
fois moi je veux jouer vraiment qu'on
soit précédent dans les choses il s'agit
pas de dire que tous les policiers sont
des pourritures
non il s'agit pas de dire que la police
française est raciste
par contre il y à des racistes au sein
de la police française
la police française à l'image de notre
société et essai et c'est ce que je
passe mon temps à essayer d'expliquer
aux uns aux autres nous moi en tant que
président de banlieues actives
on nous demande en permanence que ça
soit les politiques que ça soit les
policiers eux mêmes et nous demande en
permanence de condamner les jeunes qui
foutent le bordel dans nos quartiers
hors dons du terme mais c'est exactement
ce qu'ils disent eux mêmes on essaye de
le faire et ils ont raison et on doit le
faire et de l'autre côté l'on demande à
la police au gouvernement au ministre de
l'intérieur de faire exactement la même
chose au sein de la police lorsqu'il ya
des exactions qui sont commises parce
que justement florence parlais tout à
l'heure justement de de la formation des
policiers depuis la suppression de la
police de proximité
il ya un climat d'une violence
extraordinaire entre la police et les
jeunes dans les quartiers
il ya une défiance c'est comme deux
bandes qui se regardent en chiens de
faïence en lin représente la république
les forêts de la force de l'état à
travers la police et et puis vous avez
le citoyen de l'autre côté un endroit
normalement on est la république
normalement est une et indivisible
ils sont là pour protéger la population
donc quand vous avez des bruits des
aloses quand vous avez des brebis
galeuses il faut impérativement les
condamnés et les dégager parce que ça
rend service à tout le monde
moi je ne veux pas condamner tous les
policiers et j'ai des amis qui sont
policiers
je suis très ami avec des ddd des gens
qui sont des syndicats de police et
souvent même d'ailleurs moi quand je une
fois je me balade ils combien de
policiers parfois viennent me voir ou
des mêmes des crs qui me disent bravo
pour tout ce que vous faites on vous
suit merci de parler pour les gens
parfois et certains vous demande même
des selphy voilà donc je veux dire il
n'y a pas de ya pas de trucs on type
policier en nous comme certains veulent
le faire croire mais il s'agit juste de
dire que voilà lorsqu'il ya des brebis
galeuses que ça soit au sein de nos
quartiers avaient tous les mecs qui font
les rodéos tous les jours ou qui sont
des trafics qui confisque les rôles des
habitants oui et fallait nettoyer mais
de l'autre côté ceux qui font des
bavures policières qui font les
contrôles au faciès
parce que vous êtes noir ou arabe en
france une les statistiques sont
simplement que plus de chance de vous
faire contrôler et de vous et d'avoir
une bavure policière que lorsque vous
n'êtes pas noir ou arabe ça ce sont les
chiffres ce sont les études elles sont
larges icônes et vérifiez donc je pense
que le problème est profond et il faut
que chacun fasse un pas d'un côté comme
de l'autre
sinon en plus avec les effets du co vide
avec la casse sociale que ça va produire
je pense que c'est sûr maintenant dans
tout ça ça va être très violent pour
nous tous et c'est tout le monde
m'appelle prix pauline écoutez moi j'ai
rencontré pas mal de jeunes aussi qui
disaient contre les trois fois dans la
journée et dans la même journée ou d'un
moment la violence hellmuth est là parce
que bien peu sont des contrôles au
faciès et petit ami jean-charles
n'entend de 40 euros parce que j'en ai
que leur équipe en 30 secondes sexualisé
parce que je n'écrase east à son ami
noir 56 et 800 juifs et rock
il a son policier amis donc voilà ça
c'est fait
c'est vachement intéressant qui en
charge juste pour finir su encore une
fois choqué qu'on puisse parler de deux
bandes en disant il ya une bande ya la
police d'un côté c'est une bande et les
jeunes c'est nous la police n'est pas
une bande et j'espère qu'elle ne
deviendra jamais voilà pas autre chose
qu'une bande
l'allemagne est sur le terrain et vous
verrez oui lors d'enchères la
comparaison entre à la situation
française et la situation américaine
que ce soit au niveau des valises à
yahoo au niveau du problème social c'est
à dire aussi de deux tonnes des rapports
des blocs de bois
est ce qu'avec dsk des chenilles
semblables ou pas il ya toujours des
choses semblables c'est à dire que les
contrôles au faciès aussi ce genre de
choses et à la question de la formation
de la police que disait florent sur
l'encadrement on met tous on le voit
dans n'importe quel collège que
l'encadrement change du tout au tout la
façon dont le collège et j'irai donc ça
c'est des questions qui sont plus
transversale en revanche qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est qu'aux états unis il va
même beaucoup plus d'armes et de
violence armée et qu' il ya beaucoup
plus du but de ce fait là de peur chez
les policiers
alors je parle pas de floyd à ce flou il
ya vraiment pas de doute là dessus il ya
beaucoup plus de peur de se faire
canarder
parce que là aussi les chiffres sont là
les questions de gang et c'est devant la
défense des armes c'est pas que les cow
boy texan
voilà c'est il ya ainsi une réalité de
en parle pas de banlieues êtes est ni
quand on parle de banlieue mais ça c'est
une des spécialités quand on parle de
banlieue c'est plus tu sais plus ce
pavillon des secrétaires suarez et
classes moyennes supérieures mais
l'équivalent des des cités aux états
unis ça regorge d'armes de guerre
également et bon voilà y'a rien yahoo de
ce point de vue là il ya des
comparaisons qui sont difficiles parce
que la quantité d'armes en circulation
n'est pas la même alalala la peur de
l'autre côté la peur de ce que certains
flics de se retrouver face à un mec qui
a une arme plus deux armes trois armes
est aussi supérieure alors il y est
c'est pour ça qu'il ya certaines
comparaisons qui tiennent et certaines
comparaisons qui sont un petit peu mon
périlleuse
et bien hier guilbaud chacun justement
sur ce que disait pas que peut-être on
va commencer par vous est ce que vous
êtes inquiet de ce qui risque de se
passer dans les semaines ou dans les
mois qui viennent écoutez moi je plaide
pour que chacun prenne sa part de
responsabilité qu'on retrouve un peu de
sérénité que on ne met pas tout le monde
dans le même lot
la généralisation n'a jamais été une
bonne chose et n'est pas productive
il faut impérativement que chacun fasse
un pas vers l'autre parce qu'au delà de
la question justement des quartiers
populaires vous avez les zones rurales
et les gilets jaunes qui ont été
présents pour faire passer un message
pour dire l'autre france celle qu'ils
appellent la france d'en bas aussi on a
hélas je vous dis avec la les
conséquences de la 2e du duc au vide et
la casse sociale que ça va produire si
nous ne revenons pas et sérénité je
pense que on va vers des drames humains
pour des fonds et une fracture de notre
société qui va être très très près l'ong
a réglé ensuite en amoureux jean
baptiste là dessus mais moi je crois je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
dit rock c'est gentil ça nous a bien
raison d'être pessimiste moins heureux
il me semble que le ce se creuser entre
justement c'est ces populations qui ont
été laissés pendant l'abandon et puis le
reste comment la population est trop
important il remonte à trop loin on a vu
d'ailleurs un petit peu quelques
manifestations avec les jaunes ici là le
problème
les des banlieues qui sont complètement
à l'abandon et cette défiance avec les
portes de l'ordre et moi je crois que
tout simplement on n'a pas de bonnes
chances d'être optimiste puisque
précisément le problème n'est pas
racontée par lens pendant trois mois je
dirais j'espère
qu'il y aura du respect du dialogue du
cynisme et un peu de confiance et de
regards des uns avec les autres
jean-charles mais j'espère que la france
va pouvoir redémarrer travailler sans
manifestation intempestifs son commerce
qui brûlent sans émeute et que voilà
tout le monde soit un feu raisonnable et
que la france tu sur les mains et parce
que le pire c'est quand même la misère
que l'absence d'argent et que eux
certains fauteurs de troubles certaines
personnes qui appelle à une révolution
sont un peu inconscient voilà internet
moi je sais que dans les périodes de
crise sociale comme on va la vivre
dedans comme elles vont arriver les
divisions sont à première solution
puisqu'il ya la haine
il ya du ressentiment et qu'on peut pas
s'en prendre à un virus et qu'on peut
pas s'en prendre à wall street
donc on a besoin d'un coupable et je
pense que c'est dans ces moments que la
politique devient très importante au
sens noble et grec du terme c'est à dire
la apprendre à vivre ensemble donc on
manque peut-être à mon avis deux grands
hommes politiques qui pourraient nous
donner aussi bien aux états unis qu'en
france d'apaisement nécessaire pour
apprendre comme c'est beau de vivre
ensemble et voilà je crois que ce qui
manque et biz et voilà disons tout
simplement cela ça serait bien qu'on
arrive à vivre ensemble heureux et leur
et quel temps pour terminer mais de
mouvements
vous n'êtes plus un cri pour la
situation de l'amérique ou de situation
de la france
reste une question au sujet de la
mission
alors on a mûri cola parce que j'en peux
plus de ma gorge mais non celle aux
etats unis c'est tellement contrasté que
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment difficile
après on connaît la capacité de trump de
tours dire une nouvelle crise donc qui
sait ce que sera la nouvelle crise la
semaine prochaine avec la chine et c'est
parce qu'il faut un bouc émissaire ce
que disait à charlène le bouc émissaire
c'est toujours bien pratique parce que
ça permet de faire des contre-feux merci
merci à vous tous cet éclairage sur
l'actualité et on se retrouve très vite
au nouveau numéro de page merci encore
[Musique]